in this segment we go through another
random incidence example one that does
not involve the Poisson process but a
much simpler arrival process we do this
for two reasons one is because of the
simplicity of the example perhaps the
intuition will be a little more
transparent and the second reason is to
illustrate that we're dealing with a
phenomenon that's not specific to the
Poisson process but is much more general
the example is as follows we have an
arrival process in which arrivals happen
at random and the consecutive inter
arrival times are independent
identically distributed random variables
however unlike the Poisson process these
inter arrival times are not exponential
random variables but instead we assume
that they're either 5 or 10 minutes with
equal probability so we have an arrival
the next arrival may happen five minutes
later the next arrival Meaghan happened
five minutes later then maybe we get an
inter arrival interval of length 10 then
maybe another inter-arrival interval of
length 10 followed by one of five and so
on
what is the expected value of the case
inter arrival time well an inter arrival
time is with probability 1/2 of length 5
and with probability 1/2 of length 10 so
the average inter arrival time is 7.5
now you show up at a random time and by
random we mean a time that's completely
uncoordinated with the arrival process
you show up at some point in time and
you look at the inter-arrival interval
in which you fall and you're interested
in the length of that particular
inter-arrival interval what is the
probability that you fall inside a 5
minute
inter-arrival interval since intervals
of length five are as likely as
intervals of length 10 in the long run
there's going to be roughly as many
5-minute intervals as there will be
10-minute intervals on the other hand
the 10-minute intervals occupied twice
as much space on the real line and for
this reason it is 2 times more likely
that you will fall in a 10 minute
interval rather than a 5-minute interval
in other words the probability of
falling in a 5-minute interval is going
to be 1/3 whereas the probability of
falling in a 10 minute interval is going
to be 2/3 for this reason the expected
length of the inter-arrival interval
that you get to see when you arrive is
equal to with probability 1/3 you see a
5 and with probability 2/3 you see a 10
and this number evaluates approximately
to 8.3 which is indeed larger than 7.5
the conclusion from this example is
similar to the one that we had for the
Poisson process although the average
inter arrival time is 7.5 when you show
up at a random time you are more likely
to fall in a larger interval and for
that reason on the average you will be
seeing longer inter-arrival intervals
the calculations that we carried through
in that simple example can be
generalized for more general arrival
processes called renewal processes in a
renewal process once more the
consecutive inter arrival times are
independent identically distributed
random variables but they have a general
distribution for this case there is a
formula again that tells us the length
or the expected length of the
inter-arrival interval that you get to
see but the main message from this
example is that it does make a
difference how you sample how you choose
what to watch and what to measure it
makes a difference whether you decide
to measure the cave inter-arrival time
and its average value or to decide to
measure an inter arrival time that
chosen by showing up at a random time
the two methods of sampling give you
different results and we will see next a
few examples that have this particular
flavor